after its defeat in World War II Germany
was split into two parts East Germany
with its capital of Berlin and West
Germany with its capital of Bonn which
is here and had a population of about
110 000 people in a nation of about 50
million and given that there were much
larger more important cities in West
Germany at the time why was Bond chosen
as its capital so as of 1949 Germany was
divided into four parts and the three
controlled by the Western Powers were
merged into the Federal Republic of
Germany with the Allies preparing to
hand over the role of Civilian
government to the West Germans the first
thing that needed to be picked was where
this government would operate from and
the temporary location chosen was bomb
this was because Bonn was one of the
larger towns in West Germany that had
been bombed to ruins however it was only
supposed to be a stop Gap until the
politicians of West Germany could pick a
new capital so why did they keep it
there well there were many reasons and
numerous larger cities were put forward
Frankfurt Kelowna Munich were candidates
for the capital but all of them were
somewhat bombed and occupied the
buildings that were still standing were
either being used as a emergency housing
or by the Allied armies as bases as such
the West German government would need to
spend considerable sums of money to
build a new Parliament as well as the
massive infrastructure needed to support
it money which many at the time felt
that the government didn't have
furthermore German Chancellor comrade
Arden hour and his opponent Kurt
Schumacher didn't want the West German
Capital to be somewhere with lots of
foreign troops around Schumacher soon
found himself a little bit dead in his
successors push for Frankfurt because of
its central location they weren't in
power though so it wasn't up to them and
largely fell toward an hour and his
party to decide artanauer didn't want
the federal Republic's New Capital to be
a major city because he felt that such a
move would look permanent and thus it
would appear to be a concession that
Germany would remain divided forever
another concern was that the new capital
couldn't be anywhere with a strong
association with the previous regime
with this in mind Arden hour needed to
find a small town without Allied troops
with no connection to the war that was
large enough to house a parliament which
didn't leave much the French refused to
withdraw from any town in their former
occupation zones as they saw it as a
sign of weakness whereas the Americans
preferred that the new gov government
would be seated in a larger City but
they also refused to remove their
soldiers from there this left only the
British who had already agree to
withdraw forces from Bonn not because of
any sympathy towards German feeling but
because not stationing troops in a town
is cheaper than stationing troops in a
town and Britain was broke Bond had a
lot of unbalmed unoccupied buildings
that were suitable for use and also had
nothing to do with the previous regime
in fact it was the birthplace of
Beethoven and thus appealed to a vision
of Germany distinct from its Prussian or
imperial past and another bonus was that
it was only a 20-minute drive from
mardenauer's house and given that the
government was already there they just
well chose to stay and in fact when
Germany reunited in 1990 there was a
vote to move the capital from Bonn to
Berlin most West German politicians
voted for it to remain in Bonn however
when the votes of these German
politicians were included it tipped the
balance by a mere 18 votes and thus
Berlin took over as the new capital of
United Germany I hope you enjoyed this
episode with a special thanks to my
patrons James bisonet Kelly moneymaker
kosher wolf Sky Chappelle kartoitska
Adams
rod D Martin a firefly Y and hockey
Captain psydogboogly Wiggly Marvin
cassar Winston k word commune Miss izet
Maggie Paskowski Gustav Swan the mcgwapa
Anthony Beckett Coppertone sherwenin
spinning three plates words about books
podcast Jim Stromberg Spencer Lightfoot
and Charles the first